all the action now is here while doctors
at berlin's charity hospital try to save
alexei navalny's life
his health has become a political and
diplomatic issue
the world is watching
navalny had been in the siberian city of
tomsk
talking loudly about corrupt russian
elites and rallying those who might vote
against the russian government
there will be regional elections coming
up in three weeks from now
navalny has developed a highly effective
strategy
for opposing the ruling party in those
elections
it happened last year the last year was
extremely
important breakthrough in various
regional elections including in moscow
that's why navalny spent so much time in
jail last year
and apparently government was very
nervous regarding the election that is
coming up
navalny was still is
a very effective communicator his
youtube channel his weekly youtube show
is watched by millions of people and of
course government didn't want him to be
on air
in the coming weeks until this election
the german medics who transported
navalny and this isolation pod
obviously did not share the russian
diagnosis of blood pressure problems
for more let's bring in janna nemtsover
she is a former dw journalist and the
co-founder of the boris nemtsov
foundation for freedom
that's named after her father the
russian opposition politician
who was assassinated in moscow back in
2015.
janna welcome you know alexei navalny
and his family personally and your
father
was a close friend of his who or what do
you think is responsible for what
happened to him
so uh i'm actually thank you for
inviting me
uh i'm actually waiting for the
results of the tests which are now being
conducted
in berlin and according to the reports
from charity
they're going to reveal uh
some of their findings on monday
but my personal feeling is that
navalny was poisoned um
i think uh regarding the responsibility
you know that in russia
there are there are a lot of political
prisoners
uh putin's critics are being followed
they uh some of them were killed my
father was killed
uh just 500 meters uh
away from the kremlin wall his case
has never been sold and will never been
solved
yeah despite all our efforts uh i'm
sorry i'm sorry to jump in
uh this case i'm sorry to jump in you
you
believe alexei navalny was poisoned who
or what do you think
poisoned him who who did it
the this i cannot answer this question
but i can say that
because navwani is the most powerful uh
opposition voice uh in russia i think
that at least
uh putin vladimir putin president of
russia holds political responsibility
for his poisoning and we waited for
two days before he was transported to
berlin
and i think that high-ranking officials
tried to block his transportation to
berlin
how confident are you that we'll get to
the bottom of exactly
uh what happened to alexei navalny after
all uh
you criticized the investigation into
your father's killing uh you called it
an imitation
so i did not criticize it it wasn't a
an investigation because it was not full
it wasn't transparent
and they failed to identify the
masterminds
of those who killed my father and
moreover they failed to identify the
motive
behind my father's assassination and it
was
of course i'm pretty sure a politically
motivated
murder regarding navone as far as i know
the central investigative committee
is not going to open an investigation
into navalny's case
and it now all depends on
germans doctors whether they uh
will be able to uh find out
uh what substance uh was used
to try to attempt to kill alexina
navalny
no okay we will wait for that diagnosis
here in europe uh
more than once we've seen how dangerous
dangerous it is to
to speak out in russia is this going to
discourage the opposition
movement there
it's different to predict and we are now
all witnessing uh those massive products
in belarus and i think it was one of the
reasons
why uh navalny might be poisoned
because after the presidential elections
we saw massive protests
and despite uh state-sponsored uh
very cruel brutal repression uh we are
now witnessing on sunday
a big march uh against uh
lukashenka whom i personally
regard as former president of belarus
because he lost
the election so and i think that those
people in the kremlin including vladimir
putin
they're all frightened by this footage
from belarus
and they might think that the same can
happen
in russia in the aftermath of any
elections and you know that they are
having upcoming elections
on the 13th of september
and alexey navalny is very active and he
introduced his
wrong tactic uh of smart
vote uh it's called in russia and it's
uh it proved to be very effective last
year and
i don't think that uh russian people are
going to be discouraged
because we are witnessing growing
discontent with the policies of the
russian government
and especially growing discontent with
the fact that
putin is going to be in office for life
as he earlier this year changed the
constitution and now it permits him
to stay for life